president Trump's conflict with Attorney
General William bar appears to escalate
bernie continues to skate on his
radicalism and peabody judge takes off
the moderate mask i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show this show is
sponsored by expressvpn don't like the
government spying on you well visit
expressvpn comm / ben to stay safely
anonymous in just a second we're gonna
get to all the news of the day but first
let remind you everything is chaotic and
insane look there's a serious
possibility the democrats are about to
nominate somebody who would basically
destroy the american economy and has
pledged to do so with every fiber of his
being that might have an impact on your
stock holdings now might be a smart time
to diversify into something like
precious metals and beat the rush this
is one of the reasons why i have
recommended that people check out my
friends over at Birch gold if you
haven't yet taken the first step of
requesting a free information kit on
gold go ahead and do it if you haven't
converted a portion of your eligible IRA
or 401k to an IRA in precious metals at
least have the conversation Bert's gold
will go to work and make things super
simple for you there is no obligation
so you have nothing to lose to take that
first step Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews and a plus
rating with the Better Business Bureaus
I say everybody should have at least
some precious metals in their portfolio
as a hedge against government
manipulation against inflation against
economic downturns text Ben that's my
name Ben C 47 47 47 during the month of
February and when you open an IRA in
precious metals you get a signed copy of
my book the right side of history for
free this deal was extended from January
don't know how long it's gonna last text
my name Ben - 47 47 47 in February open
an IRA and precious metals and get a
signed copy of my book the right side of
history ask all your questions get all
the information and then when you're
ready to invest in precious metals talk
to the people I trust over at Birch gold
texts Ben - 47 47 47 that's my name Ben
- 47 47 47 alrighty so the big story of
the day is that the president appears to
be at odds once again with his own
attorney general and again this comes
from the fact that Trump simply does not
understand the value of tact he doesn't
understand what it means to just be
quiet every so often and this has led to
an open conflict between Trump who
continues to sound off like a like a
talk radio caller on virtually
everything that he
around him as though he's an observer of
the political scene and not you know the
most powerful person on the face of the
earth yesterday the Washington Post
reported that during president Trump's
Senate impeachment trial Democrats
repeatedly asserted he is not above the
law since his acquittal two weeks ago
the president has taken a series of
steps aimed at showing essentially that
he is the law now that of course is not
seriously true the president has every
authority to take people who he believes
were militating against him in the White
House and move them out of the White
House right the executive branch is a
unitary branch of government that means
the president is in charge of that
branch and he has hiring and firing
power inside that branch except for
these specified offices that have to be
approved by the Senate of the United
States it is also true that the
president's he carries along with it the
pardon power and the commutation power
which we're going to get to in just one
second I for one have long suggested
Republican or Democrat that pardon and
commutation power is stupid and should
not be given to the President of the
United States that the reason it was
originally granted was specifically to
attempt to foreclose political
prosecutions because you never know that
the next president might come in and
then immediately pardon or commute the
sentences of people who are politically
prosecuted with that said and the idea
that the President of the United States
or the governor of a state for that
matter should have the ability to
overrule a jury after a long trial
simply because that governor knew the
person or had feelings about the person
that seems to me to be a large-scale
stupidity that should be rectified
immediately
I've been again I've been consistent
about this since the Clinton
administration so this is nothing new
for me but that is indeed a power of the
presidency and president from founda
yesterday he found that pardoning
commutation but nija started hitting it
like like baby Groot in guardians of the
galaxy to you start hitting that
pardoning commutation button over and
over like who's gonna bring him a diet
coke it was it was fun times for the
president yesterday he decided that he
was going to pardon or commute the
sentences of a bunch of people so for
example yesterday he pardoned and came
he he and pardoned seven people
including the so-called junk bond King
Michael Milken there's actually a fairly
solid case for why Michael Milken never
should have been prosecuted back in the
1980s that that actually was an
overzealous prosecution but Bernie Kerik
the former New York City police
commissioner with whom Trump his friends
that guy was fairly clearly engaged in
bribery and and corruption he also
commuted the sentence of Rod Blagojevich
the former governor of Illinois who is
as corrupt as anybody who's been in
modern
American politics Levitch of course he
knew from his days on Celebrity
Apprentice if there were 11 people who
benefited from executive grants of
clemency the President issued on Tuesday
Liguilla vich of course was sentenced to
14 years in prison in 2011 for trying to
sell or trade to the highest bidder of
the Senate seat Barack Obama vacated
after he was elected president
apparently he literally was caught on
tape saying to people that he was not
going to give up that effing seat for
nothing amazing and the president
decided that it was time for him to have
his sentence commuted which is kind of
ridiculous
he also pardoned Eddie DeBartolo jr.
former owner of the San Francisco 49ers
who pled guilty in 1998 to concealing an
extortion plot by a former governor of
Louisiana he was prosecuted after he
agreed to pay 400 grand to the former
governor and when Edwards to secure a
riverboat gambling license for his
gambling consortium now again that that
one maybe looks a little bit different
in the sense that he was actually
solicited for a bribe he wasn't the one
who was actually pushing for the bribe
apparently he also pardoned Arielle
Friedler who is a technology
entrepreneur who pled guilty in 2014 to
conspiracy to access a protected
computer without authorization and
served two months in prison he commuted
the sentence of Tiny's Nicole Hall who
was sentenced in 2006 after being
convicted on various drug charges so
that one is more along the lines of his
criminal justice reform or his pardon or
a commutation of sentence for Alice
Johnson he pardoned Bernie Kerik which
is pretty controversial he pardoned
Michael Milken which is pretty
controversial but again there were a
bunch of people including the
prosecutors in his original case Milken
who suggested that he probably should
have been prosecuted he probably he
commuted the sentence of Krystle munos
who was found guilty in 2008 of
conspiring to possess with intent to
distribute marijuana and she was
sentenced to apparently two decades in
prison again that one is more along the
lines of criminal justice reform
apparently he commuted the sentence of
one Judith Negron who sentenced to 35
years in prison in 2011 for her role in
orchestrating a Medicare fraud scheme
again this is more criminal justice
reform type stuff he apparently pardoned
Paul Pogue the former the founder and
former chief executive of a large
construction company in Texas and David
Safavieh a top federal procurement
official under President Bush who
sentenced to a year in prison in 2009
for covering up his ties to Jack
Abramoff so there's a lot of accusation
that the president
engage in some form of corruption by
issuing these pardons or at very least
who's misusing the pardon power that was
clearest when it came to rod Blagojevich
she was guilty as the day is long and
really should not have been let out of
prison early with that said it's it's
the president sort of inconsistent use
of this I mean the entire House GOP
delegation in Illinois blasted the
pardon for Rob Blagojevich my guess is
the president Trump probably thought he
was doing something bipartisan because
Blagojevich was a Democrat but the
Illinois House GOP delegation which
includes Adam Kinzinger Darin LaHood
john Shimkus Mike Bosse and Rodney Davis
issued a statement saying a commutation
a blog blog way that your sentence would
set a dangerous precedent President
Trump went ahead with it anyway
and what all of this comes amidst the
president fulminating being very angry
at a lot of the Justice Department
activities surrounding for example Roger
stone there's a report from The
Washington Post yesterday that William
bar has now said that if President Trump
continues to tweet about ongoing cases
it's gonna force him to step down
according to the Washington Post Barr
told people close to Trump inside and
outside the White House he is
considering quitting over Trump's tweets
about the Justice Department
investigations foreshadowing a possible
confrontation between the president and
his AG over the Independence of the
Justice Department yesterday the
president declared that he was the chief
law enforcement officer in the country
of course that title is officially the
ag's but it is also true that the AG
works at the pleasure of the President
and so the President does in fact have
the constitutional authority to
intervene in particular cases the proper
remedy for president misusing that
wouldn't in fact be either impeachment
or the president losing an election
suffice it to say that the conflict
between Barr and Trump again it comes
down to Trump not acting in his own best
interest and people around him giving
him good advice and president Trump
ignoring it this is one of the big
problems for President Trump is that the
president is constantly doing whatever
comes into his head and then people
around him tell him this is a bad idea
and if he is smart he stops and if he is
not smart he goes ahead and he does it
anyway it is simply a fact of the matter
that the smart move here would be for
the president to stop doing these silly
things
I mean Trump himself is admitting that
he's making life more difficult for
attorney general Barr like Barr is
trying to do his job the idea that Barr
is some sort of political hack for the
president does not help the president
and it doesn't help Barr and it also
happens not to be particularly true
Trump sounding off about cases in which
Barr
has a roll is really dumb it's dumb
politics means dumb law it's dumb
politics is dumb on every level Trump as
bar says and again the president
co-owned allies are saying this he needs
to keep his piehole shot on this kind of
stuff here's Trump admitting he's making
bars life more difficult I do make his
job harder I do agree with that I think
that's true he's a very straight shooter
we have a great Attorney General and
he's working very hard and he's working
against a lot of people that don't want
to see good things happen in my opinion
that's my opinion not his opinion that's
my opinion you'll have to ask what his
opinion is but I will say this social
media for me has been very important
because it gives me a voice because I
don't get that voice in the press and
the media I don't get that voice so I'm
allowed to have a voice like he's
clearly acknowledging that what he is
saying is not helpful to him and he's
like right but I like tweeting and it's
useful to me you're the president you
have a voice I promise that podium is
incredibly powerful the President of the
United States was Barack Obama ain't not
powerful president because he didn't use
social media in the same way as Donald
Trump now I know they're a bunch of
people on the right who are screaming at
their at their speakers and at the
radios right now saying right but Obama
had the media behind him yes but Donald
Trump is the single greatest magnet for
cameras in the history of mankind if
Donald Trump were to publicly do
anything if Donald Trump were to
publicly go out and blow on a pinwheel
the media would come and they would
cover that for three hours so don't tell
me the president doesn't have a way to
funnel his message to the public without
using the dumbest possible tactics on
Twitter okay with all of that said the
reason all of that is important of
course is because the president is in
the middle of a reelection campaign
terms in the middle of a reelection
campaign a reelection campaign in which
is running against possibly the most
dangerous Democrat in the history of the
Republic to get the nomination I say
that without reservation actually I'm
not gonna say possibly I think almost
certainly in the in terms of the modern
Democratic Party now let's say post post
Woodrow Wilson because Woodrow Wilson
was actually a dangerous dangerous
individual brutally racist and all of
that Bernie Sanders in the modern era is
the most dangerous Democratic nominee
ever ever okay and I say he's the
nominee because right now there ain't
nobody stop
new poll out of South Carolina indicate
today has him tied with Joe Biden for
the lead in South Carolina which means
he wins Joe Biden has to show strong 2nd
to Nevada or this race is over for Joe
Biden and people are relying on Michael
Bloomberg to step into that gap there's
only one problem everybody on the
Democratic side of the aisle hates
Bloomberg more than they hate Sanders
because they wish to reward a lifelong
Ward of the taxpayers as opposed to
somebody who's actually built a thing
believe me I am no Bloomberg defender I
think a Bloomberg is a paternalistic
jerk I think he spends his entire life
not only bossing people around in
politics but also using his money to
shush people up
it'll get to that in just a second but
Bloomberg is not dangerous to the heart
and soul of the country in the same way
that Bernie Sanders is dangerous to the
heart and soul of the country which
suggests of course that Trump needs to
run a good race
it is incumbent on from for the sake of
the country that he not start declaring
himself quote unquote the chief law
enforcement officer of the country and
then acting with all the constitutional
prerogative is available to him in
whichever way he sees fit like use just
a little bit of common sense just like
this much
I'm not saying water it down from an
eleven to a two I'm saying water a time
from like an eleven to an eight that's
it okay but if the president doesn't do
that then he puts the country in serious
danger of having a communist as
president of the United States one gets
a Bernie in just a second I will say one
thing that is hilarious to me is these
the fact that Democrats can't understand
how President Trump has such a good
economy there's a piece by Jared
Bernstein the chief economist to former
VP Joe Biden and senior fellow at the
Center on Budget and Policy Priorities
lamenting that we have such a good
economy with such a terrible leader and
he can't figure it out and the answer of
course is that we have a good economy
because Trump doesn't bother business
because Trump is not in the business of
stopping business Trump is not in the
business of punishing success and this
is exactly the point
Bernie Sanders is in that business so if
Trump wishes to have a strong America if
he wishes to retain the presidency he
needs to run a smart race not just a
gut-level race because the fact is
whoever is the Democratic nominee has at
least a 40 percent shot of being
President of the United States okay in a
second we're gonna get to Bernie Sanders
who's indeed the clear front-runner in
the Democratic Party at this point it
scares the living hell out of me and
scare the living hell out of you not
because I think Bernie Sanders is likely
to be Trump I do not think he's likely
to be Trump but because the mere
possibility of this this ideologically
garbage candidate being President of the
United States should terrify everyone
everyone of any semblance of sound mind
should look at Bernie Sanders and say
them self forget about all of trumps
character flaws okay forget about Trump
the possibility of Bernie Sanders eaten
an 80 year old socialist who has never
produced a thing who stumps for the
destruction of America's foreign policy
military and American domestic economic
power that that person could be
President of the United States should
terrify anyone who has two brain cells
to rub together I mean I find that
terrifying the big rap on Trump in 2016
was not that he was ideologically
is that he was personally terrifying as
it turns out we have a constitution
built to stop personally terrifying what
we don't have is a constitution built to
stop ideological extremists with a solid
party base behind them because parties
have now overcome a lot of the the gaps
in the American constitutional order
we're gonna get some Bernie Sanders in
just a second who is not in fact a
typical social democrat Bernie Sanders
is a communist now we're gonna get to
this in just one second first let us
talk about our inability to predict the
future so if I could predict the future
I'd put money on this election and
presumably I would win a lot of money on
this election but I can't predict the
future and neither can you the thing you
can't predict most is what's going to
happen next in life is my wife is gonna
go into labor today I have no idea no
one knows what's going to happen next in
life and this is why when it comes to
the darkest part of life namely death
you should have life insurance insure
against the future a lot of people
predict what they think is going to
happen in the future but they don't
bother to insure for it that is an
irresponsible thing to do go get insured
right now at policy genius calm once you
apply the policy genius team will handle
all the paperwork out in the red tape
and policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home and auto insurance
or disability insurance so if you are
concerned about the future you should go
get the insurance that you need make
sure that your family is taken care of
not just life insurance home insurance
auto insurance they can even find
bundles for you they can competitively
chop all these things out policy genius
calm everyone
it's the future wrong you should get
your insurance right particularly life
insurance don't leave your family
missing not only you but your stream of
income go check out policy genius comm
right now that's policy genius calm okay
so Bernie is clearly the front-runner
and Democrats instead of realizing that
this is crisis point that we have now
reached crisis point that Bernie Sanders
who as I say is a lifelong ward of the
state I mean the man has never held an
actual job in his entire life and he is
as old as my grandparents would be okay
really that that it's amazing he is a
welfare queen Bernie Sanders Bernie
Sanders has been living off the taxpayer
dime by the way every job his wife has
ever held is is adjacent to his
government service and as we will see
that has some pretty ugly ramifications
that guy is leading the race right now
he's a clear lead in all of the national
polling all of it there's another poll
today showing him up past 30 percent so
he is picking up support as Biden fails
and as it becomes clear to democrats
that bernie is the most likely nominee
they are convincing himself that he has
the capacity to win over 70% of
democrats believe that Bernie Sanders
can beat President Trump he now has in
the RealClearPolitics polling average an
11 point lead on the rest of the
Democratic field the polling in Nevada
is solidly behind Sanders in South
Carolina the latest poll has Joe Biden
and Bernie Sanders tied which is a
disaster area for Joe Biden because if
he loses South Carolina he is toast at
that point there is a poll in California
that shows Bernie Sanders up heavy in
California as well a lot of the polls
where where Biden is the placeholder
Biden is is likely to flail out there
are two late-breaking polls from
California one shows Bernie all the way
up at 32% with the next closest
competitor Biden all the way down at 14
another poll shows by shows Bernie at
25% in Bloomberg at 21 we'll get to
Bloomberg as I say in just a second but
Bernie is the front-runner okay and
Bernie is he should again he scares me
not because I think that he is a
tremendously capable politician I don't
but because what's going on right now is
such frustration inside the Democratic
Party at the reality that Donald Trump
is president that they will vote for a
communist to stop Donald Trump this is
where we are and then now
Bloomberg I mean Sanders for his part is
going after Bloomberg but here's the
thing about Bernie Bernie is supremely
dishonest in many ways bernie is
supremely dishonest he's honest when he
says that he's a socialist who doesn't
know how to pay for his plans that
part's real but he's dishonest when he
says that he is clean as the driven snow
and pure as the driven snow I'll give
you an example so I mentioned his wife a
moment ago so there's a ad that is now
cropping up about Bernie Sanders from a
from in 501c4 that is led by somebody
who was once a staffer for Senator Joe
Manchin in West Virginia and that ad
points out that senator Bernie Sanders
supported a compact between Maine
Vermont and Texas that originally
proposed dumping low-level radioactive
waste in a small minority community in
Far West Texas
okay the waste never made it to a
community called Sierra Blanca which is
a low-income largely Hispanic town in
Hudspeth County but Sanders his efforts
attracted renewed attention online in in
in 2016 they are cropping up again those
efforts to dump toxic waste this would
be nuclear waste in the small area of
Texas that is heavily Hispanic the
Buried lead and all of that is that
Sanders his wife Jane now serves as an
alternative Commission an alternate
Commissioner for the Texas low-level
radioactive waste disposal compact
Commission question what exactly does
Jane Sanders know about the disposal of
radioactive waste I missed the part
where Jane Sanders is an expert in
radioactive waste management the answer
is of course she does not have any
expertise in that area but again she got
that job because she happens to be
married to Bernie Sanders okay also it
is worthwhile noting that Jane Sanders
got her job as the Dean of Burlington
College in all likelihood not in all
likelihood certainly because her husband
is Bernie Sanders and is a ward of the
state as has been widely reported Jane
Sanders as president of Burlington
College not only cleared a rather large
salary for herself she got a 72 percent
salary increase over six years at
Burlington College she took out a loan
which may have been taken out there's
there were investigations ongoing into
how she took out a loan to buy a large
chunk of land that ended up bankrupting
the college entirely I mean the college
literally had to declare bankruptcy but
she apparently was also funneling
hundreds of thousands of dollars to her
daughters and trustees son's businesses
privately hell
businesses Jane Sanders don't worry
socialism guys is all about honest
people doing honest things to help the
people how do we know that Bernie is
dishonest in this way I'll give you an
example so yesterday
Bernie does this Town Hall on CNN CNN's
been doing the series of town halls
where everybody gets up there and
they're asked very easy questions by a
series of increasingly sick of antics
CNN reporters and and Bernie is asked
about Bloomberg and he says I'm offended
that Michael Bloomberg is trying to buy
the presidency before gets the clip I
just one point something out every
Democrat who says that they are offended
that Michael Bloomberg by pouring his
own dollars that he earned himself into
presidential ads that that is buying the
presidency let me just point out that
Bernie Sanders has promised voters free
college tuition free health care free
housing free child care and a free and
free unicorn so he's trying to buy
voters with my money okay at least
Bloomberg is trying to appeal to voters
with his own money at least Bloomberg is
spending his own cash on why he's such a
great guy
Bernie Sanders is pledging to spend my
cash to prove to you what a wonderful
guy he is because I have far less I have
far less tolerance for this whole stop
trying to buy elections from people who
literally tried to buy elections by
promising you free crap okay anyway
here's Bernie Sanders ripping on Michael
Bloomberg for quote-unquote trying to
buy the presidency as opposed to Bernie
Sanders who is apparently spending 50
million dollars a month at this point on
advertising I do think it's a bit
obscene that we have somebody who by the
way chose not to contest in Iowa in
Nevada
in South Carolina in New Hampshire where
all of the candidates weeded town
meetings we're talking to thousands and
thousands people working on he said I
don't have to do that I'm worth 60
billion dollars I have more wealth than
the bottom hundred and 25 million
Americans
I'll buy the presidency that offends me
very much okay so he's very upset he's
trying to buy the president we keep
hearing this from people trying to buy
the presidency advertising is not buying
the presidency any more than advertising
for Nike is forcing people to buy Nike
shoes if you don't like Bloomberg you
are free not to you are free not to buy
his routine okay again you may not like
that he's buying the ads believe me the
amount of publicity he's get for buying
the ads is nearly in it's nearly even
with the amount of publicity that he
gets from the actual ad buys but this is
not a Bloomberg defense right I think
the Bloomberg Anna
paternalistic I think that he thinks he
should be President on the basis of
virtually nothing but here's the point
Sanders says he's very offended the
Bloomberg is trying to buy the
presidency and then he immediately
refuses to answer whether he will take
Michael Bloomberg's money in the general
election of course of course he does of
course he does because it's all fun and
games ripping on billionaires until you
need to seize their wealth and use it to
to control the means of production if
you're a commie
if Michael Bloomberg doesn't get it you
get the nomination would you accept if
he says look I got five hundred million
dollars left over that I'm gonna give to
you would you accept that well we're
gonna what I did say is that if mr.
Bloomberg wins and I certainly hope he
does not I will support the Democratic
nominee as of now we have not taken we
don't have a super PAC we're not asking
for a super PAC that is my position
right now so you're not sure if you
would take the money or not okay I'll
leave it there so what that is right
there is Bernie being a damn liar right
he knows what the answer is the answer
is of course he'll take the money of
course I'll take the money look Bernie
Sanders is very much against
billionaires until he needs their money
to fund his garbage schemes or his crap
campaign and says Oh spare me that he's
trying to buy the election I booked like
Michael Bloomberg is very rich he's
trying to buy the election also if you
could hand me back checkbook I would I
would really appreciate that could hand
me a checkbook but does piece of Scudder
nice Andrew says we're gonna get two
more of Bernie Sanders and the media is
unwillingness by the way to answer basic
to ask him basic questions it's insane
it's insane how has this lifelong
communist been able to escape the
media's actual hard questioning for
decades I mean seriously the only person
I've seen ask him a hard question about
nationalization of resources which he
was stumping for when he was my age okay
he was in his mid 30s and into his 40s
and he was still doing this routine he
was standing up for Nicaragua like the
dictatorship in Nicaragua when he was in
his mid 40s who's ten years older than I
am now he was standing up for Venezuela
last year he was 77 okay nobody will ask
him a tough question about this he's
just as alive so the lot of things over
the course of my career and it goes ah
ha ha well it is it's a it's
unbelievable it's unbelievable
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let us talk about what you
would do
say that you had an employee or let's
say in fact that you were an employee
who had a duty to show up to work on
time and let's say that you just didn't
do it like routinely you just didn't do
it and then you just cast aspersions and
everybody around you let's say that you
actually you know you just went around
bad-mouthing people you just talked
about like how everyone around you was
just they weren't doing their jobs and
you said it publicly right just
humiliated people publicly let's say you
were that person and then let's say you
know you thought you know maybe I'm not
the best at this maybe I need to replace
me you'd check out zip recruit calm I'm
not saying that I do all of these things
that I show up too late to work like
every single day and then blame all of
the employees around me or that I
publicly rip on them for the purposes of
advertising I don't say that I do this
but if I were to do this and then I were
going to replace me I would go check out
zip recruiter dot-com to find a suitable
replacement for me over at zip recruiter
com wouldn't post unzip recruiter it
helps you sort out the candidates bring
the best candidates to you it's no
wonder the four out of five employers to
post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the very first day if I
were going to replace me on this show I
would be checking out zip recruiter com
you can check out zip recruiter for free
at our web address zip record comm slash
daily wire at a zip recruit calm / Dai
ly WI re zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire so again now if I
were just going to replace a person who
turn up late every day to work and just
ripped on his employees like a jack like
a jackass and you know did all of that
and then cleared the check if I were
gonna replace somebody who did that I
would check out I would look for placing
me over at zip recruiter comm slash
daily wear that zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire it will work for your
business as well
zip recruiters comm slash daily wear
okay back to Bernie Sanders again it is
in act of it is just a source of endless
endless insanity to me that the
Democratic Party is preparing to
nominate this human being it's insane
the man is a walking coexist bumper
sticker as noah rothman over a
commentary put it the man is George
McGovern accept more communist yeah let
me give you a couple of examples so
Bernie Sanders let's check out his
Twitter account so these Twitter
accounts is basically
aoc without the sparkling wit it really
is here's something that he tweeted out
today
it's
it's incredible it's incredible that
this human being is taken seriously by
people it's unbelievable
so you tweets out our military is larger
than these countries combined China 181
billion dollars he has a bunch of flags
we'll see how many of these flags I can
actually identify China 181 billion
dollars Saudi Arabia 78 billion dollars
France 61 is that which one is the
vertical and versus the horizontal and
Frances 52 billion dollars I believe
France is vertical Japan is 48 billion
dollars Great Britain fifty four billion
dollars Germany 48 billion dollars South
Korea thirty nine billion dollars Brazil
twenty seven billion dollars and that
would be Italy twenty seven billion
dollars Russia is 61 billion thank you
I'm missing the Russian flag see I'm not
working for Putin so what if we invested
in human needs to care for one another
instead what if we invested in human
needs to care for one another instead
okay first of all I'm a historical level
I think it's a fairly good thing that
the United States military is larger
than Germany Japan and Italy combined
that seems like that's probably a good
idea like just looking at some history
like I'm very happy that the United
States military is hegemonic like that's
a very good thing but bernie is such a
flaming communist and he's like what if
we took our entire military budget and
we used it to pay for free child care
and we just but do we really need a
military to lodge we really need a
militant and the answer is yes to stop
people from killing us and attacking us
and wrecking our interests
the man is using the song imagine as a
campaign platform imagine there's no
countries it's not hard if you try hey
nothing to live or die for above us only
sky health how are you taking him
seriously what the hell is wrong with
you people
and then he tweets this out this is also
yesterday together we're going to end
the group of the billionaire class okay
I've just a question about this just one
question which is more greedy the local
billionaire class you know people who
created a business and then sold lots of
products and did lots of voluntary
transactions and employed tens of
thousands of people and provided
products to presumably millions of
people and made millions of people's
lives easier or the octogenarian
communist who has done zero useful
things his entire life except suck off
the
each of the state and the billionaire
taxpayer and sponsor his wife for
positions for which he is utterly
unqualified who is greedier who I'm so
sick of these of these people suggesting
that true altruism wise in sucking off
the teach of people who actually earn
it's insanity
and it says nothing with my income level
I've been saying the same thing since I
was making like fifty grand a year okay
I totally get it
this is this is absolute it's absolute
nonsense and people who buy into this it
turns out that Envy should not be a
political platform that's all this is
the greed of the billionaire so when you
become greedy it's just a serious
question like Bernie's a millionaire did
he become more greedy when his net
wealth went to a million and one when
that ticker just flipped up suddenly he
became greedy or is it the truth that as
the founders understood all human beings
have the capacity for greed and all
human beings have the capacity for
altruism and all human beings have the
capacity for sin and all human beings
have the capacity for decency but
according to Bernie because he's a
materialist Marxist he believes that as
you get richer you get more greedy and
therefore actual saintliness lies in
being a sponge right if you're if you're
Bernie and you've never done a useful
thing in your life you're actually good
you're good because you've never been
greedy don't you understand you're
taking other people's money for doing
nothing but you're not greedy because
the only way we measure greed is by your
material circumstance the richer you are
the more greedy you are therefore the
poorer you are the less greedy you are
and your personal activity doesn't come
into this at all hey this is the person
that you guys want to nominate for
president all right sure okay so Bernie
yesterday well he was on on CNN he also
decided to sound off on national rent
control so not only does he want to sync
the US economy he'd also like to destroy
the National real estate economy which
has one of the great sources of wealth
in America and has been for generations
let's just be clear about what rent
control does rent control says that you
cannot rent this thing that you built at
the price that you wish to rent it at at
the market price instead Bernie Sanders
is going to decide what you should be
able to rent your apartments for rent
control has failed every single place at
has tried why because it turns out that
you cannot have some sort of polyp
sitting above developers and deciding
what they ought to charge because
eventually developers will be like guess
what I'm not making enough money from
that I'm not gonna build I'm not gonna
build and Bernie knows that which is why
we're gonna end up with a bunch of
federally subsidized housing projects
presumably designed by Bernie and
classic East German style here is here's
Bernie Sanders talking about national
rent control as though the great the
great solution to a shortage of housing
is to create more shortage of housing by
disincentivizing development I spent my
entire childhood in a rent-controlled
apartment in Brooklyn New York and that
meant that my family at least we didn't
have a lot of money we don't have to
worry about rents you know going up by
ten fifteen percent which many Americans
do we believe that rent control is an
appropriate tool nationally to tell
landlords that they cannot simply jack
up their rents to any rate that they
want okay you know what else tells
people they can't jack up the rents to
any rate that they want you know it
tells them that the market because if I
jacked up the rates on my apartment
building to rates that people were not
willing to pay you know what happened
it's called vacancy but he doesn't
understand how markets work he thinks
that basically a developer just sits
there and then goes I'd like to rent
this place for a million dollars a month
and I'll force you to take it because
Bernie doesn't understand consent it's
amazing socialists don't understand
consent one of the things they don't
understand other idiocies Bernie spouted
last night you know I'm gonna save this
one
for just a moment because this one I'm
really gonna go off on so Bernie's
Bernie's foreign policy is just madness
absolute sheer madness we're gonna get
to that in one second first let us talk
about getting good legal advice so you
don't actually go to law school to do a
lot of stuff legally without going to a
law firm I was using Legal Zoom as a
resource for me well before I was even a
lawyer and certainly before they were
sponsor on this program over the past 19
years LegalZoom it's not more than two
million Americans start their businesses
by incorporating forming an LLC and more
but even after your business is set up
Legal Zoom can still help you out with a
lot more things like lease agreements
changing tax laws reviewing contracts
all play a part in running your own
business these are precisely the kinds
of costly hurdles that can take time
away from growing your business don't
let it happen instead check out Legal
Zoom Legal Zoom has a network of
independent attorneys and tax
professionals who can provide you advice
to address these things and more and
you'll never get charged by the hour
because Legal Zoom isn't a law firm
legalzoom.com today enter promo code
been in the box to check out for special
savings now there are certain times when
you probably will need a law firm but
for a lot of legal stuff you really
don't and why would you spend 500 bucks
an hour on a law partner when he could
spend a fraction of that over LegalZoom
and just do your will and trust yourself
for example it's legalzoom.com code ben
LegalZoom where life meets legal go
check them out right now legalzoom.com
and use promo code been in the box that
check out for special savings all right
in just a second when you get to more on
Bernie Sanders and the unwillingness of
the media to ask follow-up questions
plus we get to Michael Bloomberg and the
fact that there really are no moderates
in this Democratic race like really none
you know there are gradations it's it's
Trotsky versus Lenin at this point we'll
get to that in just one second first it
is 2020 we've only just begun what is
bound to be the most insane year for
news we've had since well probably the
last presidential election but more
insane okay because we're gonna get an
octogenarian socialist we are we are the
Democrats aren't going to stop this
train they're not gonna stop this gulag
train here now more than ever is the
time you need to be a daily wire
subscriber right now you can receive 10%
off any plan when you use promo code
Shapiro well what makes our membership
so great let me tell you you asked
members get our articles had free access
to all of our live broadcast and show
library the full three hours of the Ben
Shapiro shows select bonus content
access the mailbag and more plus our new
all-access tier gets you into the
exclusive live online Q&A discussions
with me
Andrew Clavin Matt Walsh and Michael
moles plus daily wire writers and
special guests don't forget you'll also
get the greatest of all beverage vessels
this is the one that I am about to sip
from right here as that left your
stemware just delicious again that is
10% off all those goodies when you use
promo code Shapiro head on over to daily
wear now come come join the fun you're
listening to the largest fastest-growing
conservative radio show and podcast in
the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so Bernie Sanders as I say
the fact that he's never asked a serious
follow-up question like and when he is
he has no answers ever right he'll say
things like I want them at the cut for
Oh and people say how much does that
closet I don't know I'll say so Michael
Bloomberg is a bad man when they go out
the money so will you take his money
I don't know so Bernie you said that
you're gonna release all your medical
records Bernie 'yes and you're gonna
release all your medical records you
gonna you gonna release all your medical
records here's Bernie we received a
release to rather detailed letters from
cardiologist and we received released a
letter that came from the head of the US
Congress Medical Group the physicians
there so I think we have released a
detailed report not comfortable with
what we have done just to be clear you
don't plan to release any more records I
don't I don't think we will no okay he's
not no I've decided we'll not releasing
any more medical records yes I had a
heart attack in the middle of this
campaign but I'm not releasing any more
medical records even though before I
said I would by the way his own campaign
secretary is now suggesting that if you
ask for his medical records for a near
80 year old man who had a heart attack
in the middle of the campaign but if you
ask for those medical records this is
the equivalent of birtherism of asking
for Barack Obama's birth certificate
don't worry these people are totally
sane I think the American people deserve
to know exactly as much as every other
candidate hasn't released in this race
currently and historically and what
you're seeing right now is really
reminiscent of some of the kind of smear
kind of skepticism campaigns that have
been run against a lot of different
candidates in the past I'm questioning
where they're from
um aspects of their their their lineage
etc etc this is really like birtherism
like birtherism
lineage who's what what okay so finally
Bernie Sanders sounded off last night on
CNN on foreign policy and suggested as
always that the Israeli government is
racist so Bernie who suggests that he is
proud to be a Jew it is supremely happy
it's a campaign with actual overt
anti-semites genocide all anti-semites
man I talked about this on the show
yesterday people who have overtly called
for the destruction
State of Israel which implicitly means
pushing the Jews into the sea the murder
and expulsion of millions of Jews that's
Bernie Sanders yesterday he found time
to call the Israeli government racist
quick note the Israeli government
represents a population that is 20%
Arab Arabic is an official language in
the State of Israel the only place that
is that is racially discriminatory in
Israel
seriously racially discriminatory in
Israel are the areas governed by the
Palestinian Authority there are large
red signs off the road
producer Colton can testify this because
you saw them there large red signs off
the road in Israel for the area is
governed by the Palestinian Authority
those large red signs say if you are an
Israeli citizen and you drive off this
road and you drive into this Palestinian
governed area we cannot protect you and
you are taking your life into your hands
they mean if you are a Jew because if
you're an Arab and you make that mistake
you're fine you are a Jew the great
irony is that Bernie Sanders who spends
his days defending Hamas in the
Palestinian Authority if Bernie were not
overtly anti-israel and famous if you're
just an elderly Jewish man from Brooklyn
who made the mistake of taking the wrong
turn off the road in the West Bank and
he ends it up in the middle of Ramallah
or if he ends it up in the middle of
Nablus Bernie would be a dead man
because that's what happens to elderly
Jews who end up making a wrong turn off
that road but here he is suggesting the
Israeli government is racist well
maintaining by the way he has maintained
this that we should send hundreds of
millions if not billions of dollars in
foreign aid to the Gaza Strip which
means literally handing money to the
dictatorship the terrorist dictatorship
Hamas here's Bernie Sanders being a good
Jew guys it just means like he's such a
proud you don't you understand he's
never said a good word to say about
religious Judaism every policy has ever
pushed including the dissemination of
policies that crack down on churches and
synagogues is directly against religious
Americans he stands against the State of
Israel
and when I say against the State of
Israel I mean against it he is
campaigning with people who have overtly
called for his destruction
his campaign with ill head Omar and
Rasheeda Talib and Linda Sarsour all of
whom have implicitly called for the
destruction of the State of Israel in
some cases explicitly called for that
but Bernie's a proud you guys super
proud Jew and you know how we know he's
a Jew because he has relatives who died
in the Holocaust welcome to being a Jew
okay every single Jew that I know with
the exception of some Sephardic Jews
who come from like Morocco every
Ashkenazic Jew who has lineage in
Ashkenazi Jewry has relatives who died
in the Holocaust I mean just as a
statistical matter they're only like
13.5 million Jews on planet Earth during
the Holocaust and six million of them
died six million them were murdered so
pretty much everybody has a relative who
died in the Holocaust that is not a
bonafide II a bona fide II I'm being a
proud Jew would not be hobnobbing with
people who want to murder Jews or stand
in favor of people who want to murder
Jews this is just purely disgusting
here's Bernie Sanders being a disgusting
piece of crap I should tell you that I
spent some six months of my life as a
young man in Israel I've got a cousin
who lives in Israel and I will do
everything I can to protect the
independence and the security of the
people of Israel Israelis have the right
to live in a safe and secure nation but
I must tell you this also that the be
for the Israeli people and to be for
peace in the Middle East does not mean
that we have to support right-wing
racist governments that currently do
this okay I just want to point in a
quick thing out here by the way he says
that the current right apparently is
about Bibi Netanyahu weird cuz
Bennigan's you know who else embraced
the Trump peace plan pentagons who's his
chief rival you know you know how many
Israelis actually believe that foreign
aid should be given to Hamas zero it's
me Bernie can get away with this crap
where I stand for this occurred to of
Israel but also I will do everything in
my power to campaign with people who
overtly call for Israel's destruction go
self dude seriously now it's it's not
just me saying that the Bernie never
gets asked tough questions Chris
Matthews now same page Chris Matthews
over at MSNBC yeah it's unbelievable
nobody ever tells Bernie's just full of
it he is completely fokin I come in here
I come with our show like no rumpled
every so often I had a nail directly on
the head here's me hitting a nail
directly on the head Chris Matthews go
everybody knows half the US Senate run
by Republicans it'll be half run by
Republicans next time and it takes 60
votes to get any of this stuff through
and yet nobody just says the obvious
Bernie you're full of it
none of this is going to get passed
you're gonna be a miserable president
frustrated for the first day because
you're not gonna get Medicare for all
you're not gonna get free college
tuition
for public universities you're not gonna
get perhaps of all student loans none of
this is gonna happen and you're just
gonna sit there and it's doing it so why
don't they bring that up I do not
understand
well they don't bring that up so here's
what's happening in the inside that I'm
Kryon Matthews completely right about
this completely here's what's happening
inside the Democratic Party all the same
people who are suggesting that if you
supported Trump to stop Hillary last
time empathy you bought into all of his
you bought into all of his worst
excesses you know all of those people
now those people are gonna back an
anti-american communist as their
candidate because they don't like Trump
Nicole Wallace who you'll recall at one
point I believe was a bush staffer she
says no I will definitely vote for
Sanders in order to in order to stop
Donald Trump uh you know I'll just
overlook all the fact that I won't even
ask them a tough question welcome to our
world
and partisanship is a hell of a drug
here's Nicole Wallace I'm on the record
I will vote for whomever I will I will I
will gladly and easily and handling vote
for Bernie Sanders if he's the nominee
this is not personal but my political
strategist is is like it's a four-alarm
fire in my political soul I mean how do
you how do you as a Democratic Party
tell everyone to get behind someone who
is and I don't know I have no frickin
clue what Democratic Socialist means but
everyone thinks that's what he is and it
sounds scary it sounds scary but it no I
don't know if it including means let me
tell you what it means everything he
says it means everything he says it
means okay that's that's what a
Democratic Socialist means so go for it
guys go for it
I mean we're turning ourselves into
Europe so quickly it's scary it truly is
we've turned a Republican Party that
used to be in favor of small government
limited government in order to protect
individual rights into a big government
party the Republican Party is a big
government party I mean this is an
unfortunate truth of life this is what
has happened the the Republican Party is
moving swiftly in the direction of the
British Conservative Party and meanwhile
the Democratic Party is moving swiftly
in the direction of jeremy corbyn's
Labour Party America is different
because America understood basic
fundamental precepts about America's
goodness in the world that Bernie
certainly does not accept about the
necessity for individual rights that
Bernie certainly does not accept and the
party centralizing around this guy is
scary it's the reason why I've been
saying like forget Trump versus Sanders
forget about the outcome of the election
it is a horrible thing for the
Democratic Party to be centralizing
around a radical wing that is overtly
anti-american on foreign policy like
truly believes that America is a force
for evil in the world that read Howard
Zinn and didn't see it as a
counterweight to the rosy history of the
United States or is a balance or as a
balancing perspective but instead read
it as the only thing you need to read
and then use that as their handbook the
Democratic Party has centralized around
a candidate who rejects the basic
notions of individual rights that
undergirded the country that rewrites
American history to be an unending
series of abuses and excesses it's bad
for America it's bad for America I want
a democratic party that disagrees with
me on key issues like gun control and
abortion fine disagree with me it's a
cut-in to free country but I think it's
horrible for the country to have a
Democratic Party that does not even
agree on the basic principles that
undergird a free society that scares the
living hell out of me
it truly does it meanwhile Michael
Bloomberg is now becoming the the
moderate Democrats last best hope
president Trump is going at it with
Bloomberg on Twitter and it's basically
just to New York billionaires yelling at
each other so President Trump tweeted
out what mini Mike is doing is nothing
less than a large-scale illegal campaign
contribution he's spreading money all
over the place only to have it
recipients of his cash payments many
farmer opponents happily joining or
supporting his campaign isn't that
called the payoff many is illegally
buying in the Democrat nomination they
are taking it away from Bernie again
mini Mike major party nominations are
not for sale
good luck in the debate tomorrow night
and remember no standing on boxes is
that Trump obviously is very much
bothered by Michael Bloomberg it is also
true by the way I just want to point
this out that in terms of what he's
saying about my Michael Michael
Bloomberg spreading around donations to
silence people that's been true for
years I mean he did this in New York
City he would use his foundations it's a
payoff like Al Sharpton and now Sharpton
would go away and then he just wouldn't
protest against Michael Bloomberg and he
would pay off various different sort of
groups that were angry at him to go away
and then they would go away and he's
done this in the Democratic Party too
he's seated his sort of he's seated his
with his cash that part is true as far
as that being illegal I'm old enough
remember when Donald Trump campaign in
2016 about how you bought the Republican
Party he literally said that he said I
would bring candidates in here they'd
solicit my money I'd give them I'd give
him that money and then they would do
anything I wanted and he said that sort
of stuff anyway Michael Bloomberg
responds why do you want to run against
Bernie so badly fair question I mean
it's pretty obvious that the president
would like Bernie as his as his counter
and then President Trump shot back
minibike no I would rather run against
you okay all right whatever and then
Bloomberg responded can't trust a word
you say and now you want us to believe
you see you in November okay sure
anyway the media have decided that
Bloomberg must be cast out it's amazing
the Democratic Party is centralizing
around burning they are they've decided
that they want Bernie it doesn't matter
that Bernie is a radical it doesn't
matter that he is not just a European
social democrat that he is in fact a
socialist it doesn't matter the media
have decided that they will not do this
thing they will not acquiesce ryan
cooper has a piece over at the week
called Mike Bloomberg is not the lesser
of two evils suggesting that a Bloomberg
is the nominee he will not show up to
vote for Bloomberg against Trump but
presumably he will for Bernie Sanders he
says as I've written on many occasions I
think Bernie Sanders is the best
candidate but given the abominable trump
presidency I've also said all vote for
whoever wins the Democratic nomination
but that was before Michael Bloomberg
became a serious presidential contender
then you have the New York Times New
York Times has a piece today called
Michael Bloomberg has to debate without
a net the former mayor have to set a
stand on his own because he won't be
able to just throw out ads I'm again
highly amused by the same media that
have protected Bernie Sanders from his
own explicit anti-americanism and a
variety of issues I mean explicit they
protected Bloomberg 40m Bernie for years
on this stuff now being like well
Michael Bloomberg's gonna have to get
answer some serious questions when does
Bernie have to answer a serious question
when like Bloomberg should afghans for
serious questions he absolutely should
about his treatment of women in the
1990s there are lots and lots of
allegations about him saying horrific
abusive things to women in his office
that are disgusting and disreputable he
should have to answer questions about
paying people off for their silence
which apparently was a widespread thing
that Bloomberg did and the Huffington
Post reports that when Bloomberg
plans for New York City failed to gain
popular support his vast philanthropic
network helps to gin up the illusion he
would just sort of pay people to say
things so you know all of that should
come up for debate all that should come
up for debate but the fact that Bernie's
not been asked any of these questions is
truly astonishing meanwhile there is no
other sort of moderate contender here
now Pete Buddha judge has gained no sort
of national credibility Amy Klobuchar
has gained no sort of actual credibility
the other moderates in the field do not
exist which means Bernie's Cruzan here
or he's gonna cruise right to the
nomination and the Democrats are gonna
have paved their way and we will find
out now the Republicans apparently want
him everyone except me I don't want
Bernie
I don't want Bernie not because I think
he's gonna win but because I think it's
incredibly dangerous even to have him as
the nominee but apparently the
Republicans want apparently the
Democrats want him and we're gonna get
we're gonna Rock'em Sock'em robots 2020
man Trump versus Sanders my it's hard to
think of something that would be worse
for the country than Trump versus
Sanders but we have earned all that we
bought the ticket we take the ride man
this is this is the world that we have
created for ourselves already time for a
quick thing I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like
there's a good book by Ruth Weiss who is
a professor over at Harvard University
called Jews and power and the book is
all about the relationship between Jews
and power there's sort of this this
weird notion that Jews were not anywhere
close to the centers of power for a long
period of history basically between the
destruction of the simple Second Temple
and the creation of the State of Israel
but Ruth's wife's talks about sort of
the survival of Jewish communities and
the way that that Jewish communities
existed in tension with the ruling
powers of the time how they would go out
of their way to demonstrate their
patriotism and then we're crapped on
anyway by the ruling powers of the time
because whenever you are an outsider
group living inside of states you become
the the quick subject of animosity and
we are seeing this happen again today in
Europe you're saying it happen inside
the Democratic Party in the United
States where Jews are constantly accused
of dual loyalty if they believe in the
existence of the State of Israel even
though nobody ever asks Italians in the
United States if they say we believe in
Italy nobody ever says okay well that's
because you have dual loyalty diddily
right now that's just not a thing that
comes up ever in any case the book is is
good it's sophisticated it contains a
good history of sort of the Jews
from basically second biblical the
Second Temple era to modern politics
Jews in power by Ruth Weiss she has a
new forward about modern politics and
anti-semitism you can go check that out
right now it's time for a quick thing
that I hate so orang caso I've had on
the program right I think or ins a
really smart guy he has some interesting
solutions to what he sees as systemic
problems with trade and manufacturing in
the United States he's announced the
formation of American compass which is a
new organization dedicated to helping
American conservatism what he says
recover from its chronic case of market
fundamentalism market fundamentalism is
the belief that limited government free
enterprise and individual liberty or
free markets and limited effective
government or free enterprise limited
government individual freedom or
individual liberty limited government
free markets that these are the the sort
of nystrom's
of a past age and he says without
question these principles are vital but
an emphasis so monotonous neither
supportive of effective deliberation or
genuinely conservative why don't we just
look at a policy and ask does it expand
economic freedom suggest Heritage
Foundation VP Jack Spencer because it
says Lauren caste there's more to life
than economic freedom this is we're
getting real dicey territory
he says there's more to economic freedom
than economic freedom he's gonna have to
explain that when he says a society that
attempts to maximize everyone's freedom
in every moment will fail miserably in
preserving individual liberty and
limiting government over time what is
missing from our public debates is
distinctively conservative approach to
economics the modern right-of-center
coalition is the product of the fusion
ISM and that joint economic libertarians
with social conservatives and cold war
hawks in an era when the defeat of
communism was of preeminent importance
to all three having four decades
outsourced their economic thinking's
libertarians conservatives now watch
from the sidelines as classical liberal
liberals ie libertarians and modern
liberals ie progressives debate how best
to pursue their shared and unquestioned
priorities of personal consumption and
aggregate economic growth okay first of
all I'm wondering where he is getting
the notion that modern progressives are
interested in aggregate economic growth
Bernie Sanders is not interested in
aggregate economic growth
he's not he's interested in the forest
in institution of financial equality
even at the
cost of economic growth bringing a
Barack Obama made this perfectly clear
in 2008 he was asked if you raise the
marginal tax rates and that results in
lower tax income because the economy
contracts is that worthwhile and Obama
said yes for purposes of fairness so I
don't know where Orrin Kass is getting
this idea that progressives are in favor
of aggregate economic growth they're not
orrin Kass has one side favors fewer
government programs and less regulation
the other advocates more both claim the
mantle of buzz words such as dynamism
opportunity and mobility
neither prioritizes the traditional
structures of Family and Community that
provide the foundations of a flourishing
Society or the capacities that a nation
must nurture and sustain to remain
strong see this is the part ride I don't
get it
because now Orrin Kass seems to be
conflating government programs with
traditional structures like Family and
Community like those are not part of
government I've talked consistently
throughout my career on the necessity
for a social fabric a social fabric
outside of government and conflating
government and social fabric is
precisely what the left does the left
says the government and social fabric
are one in the same and now what you're
seeing on the so-called common good
conservative right is exactly the same
sort of conflation okay well we can use
government to prop up the social fabric
as opposed to substitute for the social
fabric but which policy exactly has the
government instituted that has propped
up the social fabric in a serious way as
opposed to that same government then
being captured by the left and being
used to destroy that social fabric see
the these common good conservatives who
wish to maximize the power of government
in order to use it for their for their
own pursuits represented with which I
may agree by the way seems to be
forgetting the lesson of Lord of the
Rings which is that no one can wield
this ring and that the power of the ring
not only corrupt but also can be wielded
by your worst enemy one moment from now
against you but says Lauren cast
consensus views across the political
business and academic elite have
enormous blind spots from the dangers of
globalization it's the cost of college
for all education system the value of
belonging to a particular place at home
the data on collapsing families
shuttering communities stagnating wages
and declining life expectancy are well
known abroad America's capacity to
protect and advance its national
interest is likewise waning the problems
animate
America's resurgent populism are very
real they'll be solved neither by the
ideological alignments that governed us
into the crisis nor by that populism
itself
look carefully though and green shoots
are emerging then he quotes Josh Holley
saying that Liberty is not about
choosing your own ends he says that we
actually want to have we need to use
government basically and then quotes
Marco Rubio saying we have neglected the
rights of workers to share and the
benefits they create for their employer
which is a complete mystery of how
economics works and here's Oren Casas
conclusion he says unlike the prevailing
orthodoxy conservative economics will
take seriously the effects of social and
market forces on each other it will
concern itself with the pernicious
effect that high levels of economic
inequality can have on the social fabric
the markets functioning and people's
well-being
regardless of absolute material living
standards okay now we're in Bernie land
right if the idea is that economic
inequality in and of itself is an
inherent bad because some people are
richer and some people are poor
regardless of absolute material living
standards I don't think that that
understands the purpose of an economy
which is to allow people the ability to
trade in goods and services as they see
fit by the way that's a moral problem in
and of itself I mean there's an actual
commandment in the tent it's one of the
big ten that you are not allowed to
cover my neighbor's property okay if
you're living standard is going up and
your neighborhood standards living
standard is going up but more and you're
jealous of your neighbor and this
creates a social problem that's not a
social problem it's problem with you
being a jerk it is this is we used to
just call this envy it's one of the said
in the seven deadly sins last time I
checked in Christianity and in Judaism
again that violates the Ten Commandments
but says Oren Cass we have to take that
seriously he says that a new
conservatives conservative economics
will give weight to the value of diffuse
and widespread investments not just the
value of agglomeration it will consider
the benefits that locally owned
establishments bring to their
communities alongside the benefits that
hyper efficient conglomerates can
deliver so in other words you'll punish
Walmart for entering your community
because you want to keep the small
mom-and-pop business alive even if it
means the people don't have the option
of shopping more cheaply and then using
the extra money for their families he
says it will insist on recognizing the
importance of non market labor performed
within the household and community
rather than assuming that higher
monetary incomes in a society of two
earner families must indicate progress
well again I think that there's a lot of
importance to non-market labor performed
within the household I think that that
labor is is indeed in many cases more
important than the labor done outside
the household but that does not mean
that it is compensated in terms of money
I mean the fact is that it does have
some sort of economic benefit to keep
somebody at home taking care of the kids
I mean otherwise you got to pay a nanny
so the first thing but the idea that the
government has an involvement in that is
sort of bizarre and then he gets into
pure Marxism he says conservative
economics will also Accord equal respect
to the concerns of capital and labor as
I've discussed on the program many times
the false division between capital and
labor is a really interesting one
because if you are a if you are a worker
at a company and you also own a 401k are
you capital or are you labor because you
own stock in some other company so we
are a capitalist when it comes to your
401k but you're a labourer in terms of
your salary also the reason why you are
earning a salary and presumably you're
not invested in the company in terms of
stock is because you are interested in
short-term gain right which is the
salary right you're earning more from
the company then most stockholders will
earn from the company in that year
because most people don't just get a
dividend and even if they do get a
demand it probably is in 50 or 60 or 100
grand which is the salary that you're
earning from the corporation right as a
laborer you are being compensated as an
employee you are being compensated this
division between capital and labor as
though capital is just there to harm
employees and as the labor is only there
without reference to the future of the
corporation that isn't true either
because if you're a laborer you do have
a stock in the future of the corporation
because you want your job to be there
tomorrow presumably he says conservative
economics will Accord equal respect to
the concerns of capital and labor rather
than claiming that whatever is best for
shareholders in the short-run will
eventually prove best for workers as
well hey well well nobody suggest that
if you have a management that only looks
at the short term that that management
is doing its best for the workers or for
the shareholders by the way like how
many shareholders are very much in favor
of owning stock that they believe will
not be there ten years from now
nobody buys stock thinking that or at
least very few your short sells stock
thinking that but I don't buy the stock
thinking that is it well favored
collective work a representation that
affords real influence in terms of
setting in terms and conditions of
employment over the fiction
that individual employees enjoy the
freedom to each negotiate their own
terms and now he is something in favor
of a Bernie Sanders plan it sounds like
in which half the board is made up of
worker representation which means lower
rates of investment lower rates of
capital lower rates of economic
movements inside businesses you can't be
quite as entrepreneurial if you have to
consult with people who wish to raise
their own salaries which is what
presumably the labor bargaining would do
we did try this in the 1950s and 60s by
the way it's completely destroyed the
auto industry in the United States and
then the notion we've never tried this
before is just not true
unions were incredibly strong in the
auto industry in the 50s 60s and 70s by
the 80s virtually all of our major car
manufacturers were bankrupt specifically
because of those deals test says it will
be aware that cheerfully abandoning the
world's industrial supply chains to Asia
was is and always will be irresponsible
well I mean not necessarily it depends
on the nature of the supply chain we
have supply chains for t-shirts is the
idea that we need to make t-shirts in
the United States we can't make them in
Vietnam anymore because the price of
t-shirts is going to go up I mean we are
both consumers and producers okay bottom
line he says our goal for American
compass this is the new movement is to
reassert ideas like use for a
conservative coalition that once
understood them intuitively because they
are natural outgrowths of conservative
principles well no now you're miss
defining conservatism conservatism was
based on the idea that we are that we
are creatures created by God with
individual rights that pre-exists
government and a limited government is
created in order to preserve those
rights I don't know what conservatism
he's talking about presumably that
conservatism is one that suggests that
the be-all end-all is institutions like
family preserve and forwarded by
government but that is kind of different
from America that's more European
conservatism than American conservatism
that doesn't mean American conservatism
is anti-family just sees a different
role for the government and particularly
between the state and the local and the
federal government I think that they've
local governments want to shore up
families with social programs that's
their prerogative and I don't really
object to that if you wanna live in one
of those communities here's an America
must reorient its political focus from
growth for its own sake to widely shared
economic development that sustains a
vital source which shows social
institutions first of all I don't
understand growth for its own sake
growth for its own sake is resulted in
the greatest prosperity in the history
of humanity seriously like that's kind
of a good thing
does that growth for its own sake that's
growth for the sake of the seven
billion people who live on planet earth
and yes the 330 million Americans who
live in material excess in the United
States he says we must set a course for
a country in which families can achieve
self-sufficiency contribute productively
to their communities and prepare the
next generation for the same that all
sounds great but it has a no limiting
principle meaning that this could easily
support an Elizabeth Warren or Bernie
Sanders Jenna he says all this requires
an economic consensus that emphasizes
the importance of family community and
industry to the nation's liberty and
prosperity
yeah that's incredibly vague and if what
we are calling for in the end is a is a
movement that puts governments at the
heart of American conservatism and then
that means the destruction of the
village in order to save it already
we'll be back here a little bit later
today with much more content and stay
tuned because tonight's Michael
Bloomberg is on stage you will be the
center of attention because every
Democrat is determined apparently to
make Bernie Sanders the nominee look by
the way final comments on the debate
tonight look for the murder-suicide from
Elizabeth Warren directed at Michael
Bloomberg right the the patented chris
Christie Marco Rubio presidential debate
murder-suicide in which a candidate who
will not win the nomination takes out a
candidate who could win the nomination
and then ends up destroying their own
career in the process watch for
Elizabeth Warren to do this to Michael
Bloomberg tonight while Bernie just sits
there going I look like I have stupid
ideas but nobody's gonna stop me
no one's gonna stop me are you oh man
alright well we'll be back here tomorrow
recap all of it i'm ben shapiro this is
the bench bureau show
the Benton Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel Whitehouse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SIA vets audio is mixed
by Mike rapport Amina
hair and makeup is by Nika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
the left has long blamed President Trump
for just about every political problem
Under the Sun they blamed him for the
Sun itself and how much it's heating our
planet that's par for the course
but Trump derangement syndrome has now
progressed just so advanced a stage that
the American left is blaming President
Trump for schoolyard bullying we will
examine who the real bullies are and how
they get away with it then postmodern
Pete Buddha judge declares words have no
meaning everyone comes out as queer and
president Trump pardons a couple of
jailbirds all that more check it out on
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]